c'est une tradition à châteauroux quand
un ancien président meurt une rue de la
ville est baptisée à son nom
place de la république l'hommage se
prépare drapeaux en berne faute aux
endeuillés sono tout est prêt je verrai
une rumeur plutôt agréable où il ya du
passage m'a tant qu'à faire
bien qu'ils soient représentatifs de
notre ancien président tu as quelques
pas avenue du général de gaulle
anciennement rue nationale les passants
passe et pense
des fois on sait même pas où est le
problème et non mais non je ne pense pas
forcément
charles de gaulle quand je viens ici me
promener j'aurais préféré donner un nom
de rue plus grand à jacques prévert par
exemple voilà l'avenue valéry giscard
d'estaing devrait se situer dans le
quartier balzan avec les autres
présidents l'auront point lucie aubrac
grande résistante conduit déjà au choix
vers l'avenue charles de gaulle la toute
nouvelle avenue jacques chirac et
l'avenue françois-mitterrand à gauche
avec l'écho campus et l'iut pour xviiie
siècle c'était le chemin de la
manufacture royale de draps puis de
véhicules et d'artillerie
les temps changent place de la
république l'heure est à l'hommage
minute de silence marseillaise discours
à celle qui fut à la fois notre
président de la république faisant
entrer la france des années 70 dans la
modernité mais aussi un esprit brillant
et un ardent défenseur de l'union
européenne c'est quelqu'un qui a qui a
fait énormément pour le pays qui a mes
parents étaient de petits agriculteurs
quand ils ont eu leur retraite
elle était bien amélioré par le
président le choc de
valéry giscard d'estaing sera traité au
conseil municipal en février
pour moi c'était mon premier président
il était en fonction j'avais annonçant
simplement donc je peux pas dire que je
me rappelle de son mandat effectivement
la révolution des années mitterrand
derrière a fait qu'il ait rapidement et
certainement injustement tombées dans
l'oubli des panneaux retraçant
l'histoire et les réformes des anciens
présidents devraient être installés dans
leurs artères respectives avenue jacques
chirac anciennement rue du pont neuf au
pied du château raoul les habitants se
souviennent que lors du changement non
ils ont dû refaire les cartes grises et
tous les documents officiels